willkommen zu einer neuen folge bett
wars und heute gibt es eine ankündigung
zu machen denn oh ja in den nächsten
tagen genauer gesagt morgen der domain
übrigens mit dabei dieses wesen
dann habe ich angefangen und in den
nächsten tagen liebe leute wird ein
neues projekt kommen eine neue serie die
alles was es bisher an adventure match
gab in den schatten stellen wird
so ist es zumindest bei mir ich
persönlich hatte ich den eindruck dass
schon die ersten folgen aufgenommen das
ist einfach kann das ist irgendwie next
level dieses ding da und zwar ist das wo
man schon sagen oder man mich noch nicht
noch nicht
also leute morgen auf jeden fall wie
soll man es nennen es ist keine
adventure web ist es irgendwie es ist
irgendwie so ein zirkus den spielplatz
irgend sowas in minecraft hat so viele
verschiedene sachen machen kann es so
unfassbar vielseitig dieses ding und
dann machte damit den bogen hier weil
ich bin aber ich leite hat nebenbei hoch
ich habe als ultra kassel extra wie okay
dann haben wir haben ich finde nicht
viel anfangen
der damals bisschen gehandicapt heute
aber das funktioniert sonst hat auch
aber heute noch mehr als sonst
später ruhm hier im bogen bogen pfeile
deswegen gebe ich keine schlechte idee
genau weil der dom hat wieso und die
ultra lex seine internet- und krepiert
einfach gerade weil in dem bei hochlädt
ein penis gerade 260 jahres ist schon
richtig drama 1 wird mache ich mir sehr
gerne aber alles andere ich kann auch
mal gerne raschen und so okay vielleicht
sollten wir erstmal bei uns hier drinnen
bisschen hoch bauen weil nicht eingebaut
oder vielleicht da aufpassen
kannst du vielleicht aufpassen und ich
rasch alleine wäre es damit im jahr
ich müsste doch wissen wo das bett des
bettes in der stadt und in der tür
ok blau ist ein einzelner ich glaube ich
immer blau
ja ein sonntag und die später gründete
ja ja die einzelnen kann man später ich
glaub grün kommt zu uns gerade wenn ich
das richtig sehe er einen nicht ganz
okay einen hab ich geholt
von team green der sich vielfältig
kommen hier ja ich weiß nur der
priorität alter ich gar nicht
ok ok ok gelb gelb mache zehn grad
vormarsch auf blau dann nutze ich das
auf gelb zu gehen hoffentlich gegen die
blaue rechtzeitig kaputt genial ist
drehte die und du guckst bisschen dass
bei uns keiner rein statpro ich wollte
ein bisschen zu ja ja somit mit damit
ist der mitte gerade coco coco politik
ist weg und ist relativ kräftig
zugenommen
über tab erleben es um geld
und auch alle beide weggeholt sehr schön
gut will ich soweit alles gut gelbes
raus blau ist nur noch ein mann
gelb ist gerade an blaue schemmer
ziemlich heftig gescheitert wir sind wir
rot doch ja wir sind champion und tieren
heißen wir und typischen in tirol
spielen bald eine eine ganz tolle ich
bin okay ich glaub ich geh jetzt auf
grün
ja mach du mal ich kann ich hole mir die
schule die eska lenkwaffe macht gemacht
sein verein die studios vor you only for
you auf 5 gold ich könnte theoretisch
auch wissen was service community
service nein ich kann mit meinem arzt ok
jetzt ist jetzt grün kann so ein
bisschen raus rennen
ich komme zu dir leute nicht eingebaut
grünen ist kaputt
die zerstörung ist sehr schön okay jetzt
kann man es mit mit mit blau.de bisschen
zeit lassen den kommers bisschen folter
er kommt bei dem die mitte aufpassen er
macht gar nichts enden so ich habe es
mal ein schwert auf jeden fall eine
dingen spitzhacke sehr gut wie viel ich
habe fünf gold da kann ich dir noch
wegen dumping du bist echt wissen ein
bisschen gehandicapt gerade aber heute
wie gesagt schreibt euch das indy
hausaufgabenheft morgen um 17 uhr 17 usd
teil bei mir zumindest die erste folge
der neuen serie und ich glaub ich hab
versprechen wenn ich sage das ist
wirklich die beste map ist
die ich bisher kann dann gehe ich mit
rein kann man von oben spam
wir können ihn halt noch ein bisschen
foltern so wir können halt noch ein
bisschen folter und ganz nachvollziehen
kaputt hauen kann ich wusste was ein
freund des sports meisten dann bauen wir
ein bisschen ein jahr klappen so
zwischen block gut dann so genau wollte
mal wissen weiter ein so okay da drin
ist aber dem blog der kanal kann daraus
habe ich hab' ich hab' ich hab ich halt
gemacht hat alles kaputt gemacht sehr
schlechtes gewissen weil dann ein
bisschen höher bauen finden einfach
nicht der abbau nein nicht so müsste
daran schlagen ist jetzt richtig an
uralte debatte was traust gerade machen
jetzt folgendes wir machen jetzt folgen
danach habe ich eine coole idee dass man
das mal in ordnung was man in ruhe also
wenn ich noch nicht kaputt von ihm hatte
ich muss aber darauf achten dass er ja
nix abbaut
ja ich habe jetzt erst mal schlagen
schreibt gerade wieder nicht reingeht
diese tumor der sollte gleich
unterschiedliche nein ich hab auch noch
sah ich hab's ja ja ja ja ja ja wenn das
funktioniert alter wenn das funktioniert
und geht drauf geht drauf getroffen ist
kaputt gehen ist ja nicht ich hab mich
kaputt von ihm ist egal
und das wird ihn zu küssen
aber egal leute das neue heim trick
mathematik mit der antwort und der hand
mit der hand ich backe block nicht
blockt alles klar so gut handschin the
twisted ambience entscheid wann wie bei
ihrer kollegin und da gilt der
wunderschönen leute wie gesagt das gerne
daumen nach oben
heutige folge gefallen hat das projekt
mit mohammed morgen startet das projekt
startet morgen 17 uhr
seid dabei jackpot reinders unten
verlinkt übrigens auch falls er denn
noch nicht kennen können jetzt schon
anschauen und euch da mal anschauen wer
mit mir da in dieser serie am start sein
wird ja heute einfach zu gut und